it seems at first weird that we might
learn from Thomas Aquinas he was a
medieval Saint who was reputed to have
levitated and had visions of the Virgin
Mary he was much concerned with
explaining how angels speak and move and
yet he continues to matter because he
helps us with a problem which continues
to the devil us how we can reconcile
religion with science and faith with
reason Aquinas was both a philosopher
and a saint refusing either to lose his
faith or mindlessly believed he
developed a new understanding of the
place of Reason in human life Aquinas
his monumental contribution was to teach
Western European civilization that any
human being not just a Christian could
have access to great truths whenever
they made use of God's greatest gift to
human beings reason Aquinas broke a
logjam in Christian thinking the
question of how non-christians
could have both wisdom and at the same
time no interest in or even knowledge of
Jesus Aquinas universalized intelligence
he opened the Christian mind to the
insights of all of humanity from across
the ages and the continents the modern
world insofar as it insists that good
ideas can come from any quarter
regardless of creed or background
remains hugely in Aquinas is debt Thomas
Aquinas was born to a noble family in
Italy in 1225 as a young man he went to
study at the University of Naples and
there came into contact with a source of
knowledge which was just then being
rediscovered the texts of ancient Greek
and Roman authors Aquinas then became an
academic at the University of Paris and
an exceptionally prolific writer
producing nearly 200 pieces about
Christian theology in less than three
decades his books bear beautiful and
strange titles like the Summa Theologica
and Summa contra
teyla's such was his devotion to
knowledge even at the moment of his
death
at the age of 49 Aquinas is reputed to
have been in the middle of writing an
extended commentary on the song of songs
after he died he was canonized in the
Catholic Church and is now the patron
saint of teachers Aquinas his starting
point was that some of the world's
greatest thinkers have not been
Christian but this didn't bother them
from having huge insights because as
Aquinas proposed the world can be
usefully explored through reason and not
just through faith to explain how this
could work Aquinas brilliantly proposed
that the universe and all its dynamics
operate according to two kinds of law
secular natural law and religious
eternal law for Aquinas a lot of the
world follows natural laws we can find
out for ourselves how to smelt iron
build an aqueduct to organize an economy
and none of this relies on believing in
God Aquinas discussed Jesus's injunction
to do unto others as you would have them
do unto you Jesus may have given this
idea a particularly memorable
formulation conceded Aquinas but it's in
fact been a cornerstone of moral
principles in most societies at most
times how could this be possible well
the reason Aquinas argued is that it's
an idea that belongs to natural and not
eternal law Aquinas conceded that in a
few situations God does work simply
through eternal law outside of human
reason and he cited prophetic
revelations and the visits of angels as
examples however he reassured us that
most useful knowledge can be found by
atheists and secular minded people
within the realm of natural law Aquinas
his ideas unfolded at a time when
Islamic culture was going through very
similar dilemmas as Christianity in
terms of how one can reconciled reason
and faith for a long time the Islamic
caliphates in Spain Morocco and Egypt
had flourished by being open to
knowledge from all over the world
generating a wealth of new scientific
idea
and philosophy however due to the
increasing influence of fanatical
religious leaders Islam had become more
dogmatic and oppressive by the time
Aquinas was born it had for example
reacted violently against the Muslim
philosopher Ave arose like Aquinas
Averroes had been deeply influenced by
Aristotle and had argued that reason and
religion could be compatible however the
caliphates anxious never to depart from
the literal words of God made sure that
Averroes his ideas would be banned and
his books burnt Aquinas knew that the
Muslim world's increasingly radical
rejection of reason was harming what had
once been its thriving intellectual
culture and it was overwhelmingly thanks
to Aquinas his ideas that Christianity
did not suffer the same process of
stultify keishon though Aquinas was a
man of deep faith he provided a
philosophical framework for open
scientific inquiry he reminds us that
knowledge can and should come from
multiple sources from intuition but also
from rationality from science but also
from revelation from pagans but also
from monks that sounds obvious until we
notice just how often civilization has
been and is still being harmed by
people's refusal to take this brilliant
idea on board
you